10 facts about Jiu Jitsu Kaizen that I
guarantee you didn't know number one
megami's grandfather was the former
leader of the Zenon clan in volume 17 we
got this official diagram of the Zenon
family tree and it revealed that the
previous head of the family was toji's
Dad meaning that he was also fushiguro's
Grandad what makes this fact even more
interesting is that it's highly likely
that Grandpa also possess the 10 Shadows
technique there are two main reasons why
I'm sure about this the first is that
during this flashback it was implied
that when Megami was born his
grandfather was already dead we know
this because the new head of the clan
was now Beto meaning that at this point
in the timeline no one in the Zenon
family had the 10 Shadows that's why in
chapter 130 naubito was so interested in
megami's potential because as the direct
descendant of the last 10 Shadows user
there was a realistic choice that he'd
inherit the technique the second reason
why grandpa had the 10 Shadows is that
when it comes to the big three Clans
they always want their leader to be
someone who has the family curse
technique an example is is how the Como
Clan wanted narutoshi to be the next
head even though his mother was a
mistress and it's also like how naobito
wanted Megami to be the next leader of
the zenin even though he's literally had
nothing to do with them his whole life
according to the author the Gojo clown
is the same in that they choose their
leader purely based on who was born with
the sixth size or the Limitless curse
technique so bearing all this in mind
it's likely that naobito's predecessor
must have had the 10 Shadows which is
where Mega me gets it from number two
nonami was originally supposed to be a
villain in an interview in 2021 gege
revealed that his original plan was
phenomy to be a bad guy who worked for a
shady company and then one day loses his
mind and kills everyone there after that
he was supposed to follow a group of
evil Sorcerers and face off against Yuji
but later down the line they were meant
to become friends this fact is amazing
simply because it's so easy to imagine
it because nanami even said himself the
corporate world is crap and juicy
Sorcerers are also crap so as a villain
it makes sense to see him literally
attacking both groups number three
during the Shibuya Arc Luffy from One
Piece made a brief cameo in chapter 83
there was a scene where Gojo was trying
to figure out what the villains were up
to and he flies over a crowd of people
who were dressed for Halloween in that
crowd is this one person who's wearing a
straw hat that seems to also have the
same hair as Luffy which makes you
wonder is this just a really good
cosplayer or is gear 5 so overpowered
that he could now just travel between
different series number four in volume
13 of jusu guys and gege explained the
full story of playful cloud in case you
don't know playful cloud is a special
grade cast tool and has been passed
around more than any other weapon the
first person to have it was toji
fushiguro and he stored it inside this
cursed spirit that he carried around
with him following toji's death ghetto
then took control of the Spirit by using
his curse technique and in the process
playful Cloud became his in the jjk
movie he whips it out during his fight
against Utah and after he loses Gojo
takes the weapon back however the Zen in
Clan argued that since toji was the
original owner the weapon technically
belongs to them and so Gojo used his
influence to make sure Marky was allowed
to have it in the Goodwill event Mega me
then stores it inside his shadow having
no idea that it used to belong to his
dad and he and Marky then use it to
fight against Hanami Toto then has a go
using it after them and things then come
full circle when toji's Soul uses it for
the last time number 5. Tangen is by far
the oldest sorcerer introducer Kaizen
but did you know that this is what she
originally looked like although her
curse technique makes her Immortal she
still goes through the aging process and
so every 500 years she needs to reset by
absorbing another person in one chapter
we saw that there were at least three
previous vessels meaning by default
tangin has to be at least 1 500 years
old number six when Gage originally
began writing the series he never
expected to continue beyond the events
of volume zero as far as he was
concerned the story ended with rika's
curse being broken and his plan was to
start writing a new anger about a
Japanese idol that being said when the
chapters turned out to be more popular
than expected his editor advised him to
keep expanding the jjk universe this
helps to explain why Concepts like
domain expansion weren't included in the
climax of volume zero because gege
generally hadn't thought of it yet
number seven back in the superior
konjaku tricked Everyone by secretly
using his gravity manipulation as we now
know kanjaku has the power to mess with
gravity which is a curse technique that
he stole from yuji's mother during the
Shibuya Arc though we had no idea that
he had gravity related powers and so
when the prison world was forcefully
slanted to the ground there was no
reason to suspect that kunjaku was
secretly responsible now you might then
be wondering why he'd do something like
this in the first place and the answer
is that it gave him the excuse he needed
to separate himself from the rest of the
group remember at this time mojito and
Drogo wanted to chase after Yuji for
their own reasons but kenjaku didn't
want to go with them in his mind he was
planning to betray the curse Spirits
later that same day as though he wanted
them to fight Yuji alone so that they
would grow in strands before he takes
control of them using cursed Spirit
manipulation to put it another way
kanjaki believed that separating himself
from the group had the potential to make
himself even more powerful in the future
however obviously he needed a good
excuse for why he's staying behind which
is why he activated his gravity on the
prison realm and then acted like he
couldn't leave the area in Chapter 93
you even noticed that in this panel
mehito becomes suspicious of him for the
first time and his coushaku is lying to
their faces and trying to trick them
anyhow fact number eight is that back in
the day when Gojo and ghetto were
students toji tells ghetto to thank his
parents for giving him such a great
technique the reason this line about
thanking his parents was so ironic is
because when ghetto turns to the dark
side later on his parents were some of
the first people he killed number nine
you might have noticed that in the
Jujitsu Kaizen prequel Gojo was wearing
bandages around his eyes instead of the
blindfold that he has in season one
according to the reason for this change
is that it's hard to draw bandages every
week especially compared to the simple
design of the black blindfold on top of
that when writing the prequel series he
didn't really have a clear idea on how
Gojo's Powers worked but when the series
unexpectedly became popular he was
forced to do more research about the
concept of infinity finally fact number
10 is that in the first chapter there
was a subtle hint that Yuji is a death
painting in case you're not sure what
that is the death paintings are a group
of people who were both half human and
half-car spirit the first death
paintings were created by kinjaku 150
years ago but Yuji is basically the new
and improved version which is what made
him the perfect vessel for suppressing
sukuna's Soul at this point certain
characters in the manga have outright
confirmed that Yuji is related to the
death paintings meaning he is definitely
part curse now if we flash back to
chapter 1 notice how Megami explains
that curses will be attracted to the
sukina finger that was hidden at yuji's
school at the time it didn't really seem
that important but now that we know that
Yuji is a cuss himself it makes perfect
sense why he was the one to find
sukuna's finger before anyone else the
finger attracted him to it just like a
cursed spirit and it's why itsadori felt
compelled to take the box in the first
place despite not knowing what was even
inside
with that said those were 10 facts from
Jiu Jitsu Kaizen that you probably
didn't already know let me know in the
comments which one was your favorite or
if I've missed anything that you think
should have been included if you enjoyed
this video then I'd really appreciate if
you SOB so you don't miss future content
like this and hit that like button as it
does help out with the algorithm until
the next one peace out